foreign
thanks uh this talk is not going to be
about optimization
so I just finished my PhD at UT Austin
under the supervision of Scott Aronson
and I'm starting uh well just a couple
weeks ago as a postdoc in the quantum
pod I'll be here for the next couple of
years and today I'm going to tell you
about
um
some work based uh in part on joint work
with lowenchen macron simha and Avi
chaital on the possibility of building a
Quantum cryptography without one-way
functions
um
the title of this work Quantum
cryptography in alphabetica refers to
one of impogbiatsu's five worlds which
presumably many of you are familiar with
um these are basically five possible
resolutions to the P versus NP problem
that were introduced in this influential
survey about average case complexity uh
in the
1990so uh and these five worlds range
all the way from algorithmica where p is
just equal to NP and so a wide range of
problems can be solved efficiently in
polynomial time all the way down to
crypto Mania where p is different from
NP in such a strong sense that you get
really powerful cryptography like public
key encryption
and if you're a classical cryptographer
uh you generally hope that we live
somewhere below this line in either
minicrypt or cryptomania because what
characterizes uh whether you're above or
below this line is the existence of
one-way functions which are widely seen
as being the minimum computational
assumption that you need in order to get
interest in classical cryptography
and uh just to remind you because
presumably not everyone here is a
photographer a one-way function that's
just a function that's easy to compute
but it's hard to invert so for any
polynomial time adversary given f of x
for random input X it should be hard for
the adversary to find a pre-image of
that function with better than
negligible probability
and the reason why one-way functions
play such a central role In classical
cryptography is that as I kind of
alluded to earlier they're both you know
widely seen as necessary but also in a
way sufficient for wide squats of
classical cryptography necessary in the
sense that for pretty much any super
polyamally secure classical crypto
system you can generally show via a
reduction that if that crypto system if
a secure instantiation of that crypto
system exists then you can build 1A
functions from it but conversely money
functions actually also turn out to
suffice or a lot of interesting
cryptography including things like
pseudo-andm generators pseudonym
functions uh digital signatures and
commitment schemes to give a few
examples
uh kind of the question we ask is that
you know in the classical World one-way
functions seem to be the minimal
computational assumption that we can
make to get cryptography what happens in
the quantum world and in particular are
one-way functions necessary in the
quantum World both in the sense of you
know our one-way functions themselves
still the minimal computational
assumption that we need for Quantum
cryptography uh and if not then what
really are the the minimal assumptions
that we can make that would allow us to
build uh secure Quantum photography
and
um already in the quantum World some
interesting phenomena of here their
heads
um
for example there are these these
protocols uh like this one on the left
the the so-called bb84 uh Quantum key
distribution protocol that was
introduced by Bennett and brazard where
they showed that uh two spatially
separated parties Alice and Bob who
share an unsecured Quantum channel can
securely exchange a secret key over that
channel in a way that cannot be learned
by any eavesdropper
um who who listens in on that channel
where uh the security proof of this is
actually unconditional so it's an
information thematic proof relies on no
computational assumptions and this is
obviously something that we cannot do
classically right classically if you
want uh key distribution
then you need to make some sort of
computational assumption I won't talk
about this other example on the right
but this is sort of another example of
something you can do quantumly that you
can't do classically involving Quantum
money so certainly in the quantum
setting if we allow cryptographic
protocols that are implemented via
Quantum communication between the
parties then already you can start to do
things that you can't do classically
um but this is not the end of the story
so you can't just hope to build
everything uh
via a similar group where you just have
information theoretic security because
you can show that for most cryptographic
tasks that we care about you still need
to make some computational assumptions
on the adversary in other words you
cannot have information theoretic proofs
including things like symmetric key
encryption commitment schemes and
digital signatures these sort of mini
Crypt Primitives that we know how to
build classically from one eye functions
but also for some of these like stronger
kind of inherently Quantum Primitives
like publicly verifiable Quantum money
or Quantum copy protected software again
you can show that you cannot have
information theoretic instantiations of
these printers
so where does that leave us well you
know one thing that's that people have
basically tried to do in recent years is
they've tried to say okay what if we you
know Define quantum analogs of these
classical Primitives like 1A functions
or pseudo Dynamic generators then maybe
we can both try to see a can we build
cryptography from those Quantum analogs
and B can we try and understand you know
what computational assumptions you need
to to actually build those Primitives
and um a very well known example of this
maybe kind of the first uh that was
introduced recently uh was in this paper
by G Lew and song in 2018 of what are
called pseudorandom Quantum States
and intuitively you can think of
pseudonym Quantum States as being kind
of a Quantum analog of classical
pseudonym generators so
um it's on a key to Ensemble of quantum
states that you can generate efficiently
uh and it has this computational
indistinguishability Criterion which
just says that for any polynomial time
adversary the adversary cannot
distinguish copies of a random straight
drawn from uh drawn from the pseudonym
Ensemble from copies of a uniformly
random or sometimes called A Hard random
Quantum state
and indeed there's really basically only
two differences compared to the
definition of pseudonym generators one
is that rather than trying to mimic the
uniform distribution Over N bit strings
you're trying to mimic the uniform
distribution Over N qubit Quantum states
that the harm measure in red
and the other difference in blue is that
in general we will allow the adversary
to have access to any polynomial number
of copies of the state that it wants
this is kind of justified by the no
cloning principle and quantum mechanics
where you can't take an unknown Quantum
State and produce a copy of it so we
might as well
um
yeah see what happens if we give the
adversary more copies in some cases that
lets the adversary do things that
otherwise could not
um
and there's kind of three big reasons
why we uh well my two random states have
gathered so much attention in recent
years
uh the first is that they actually
suffice for a lot of these uh
photography things that we can build
from uh 1A functions and in fact even
some things that we don't know how to
build uh from one eye functions Alone
um but they suffice for things like
commitments some form of digital
signatures some uh some part of secure
multi-party computation and
computational Co knowledge again all
involving some form of quantum
communication between the parties
uh it has also been shown that the
existence of pseudonym States has
actually implied by 1way functions so if
you believe that when a functions exist
or at least if you believe that Quantum
is functions exist you should certainly
believe that pseudonym States also exist
there are no stronger a computational
assumption
and finally there's uh some evidence
some some recent evidence to suggest
that perhaps pseudonym states are
actually a a plausibly weaker assumption
than 1A functions and this is going to
be what I'm going to talk about for this
this is what my work really touches on
and
um uh what I can show in in these you
know uh a couple of words one by myself
in 2021 and one with some co-authors
from this year what we can show is that
in the Black Box setting uh you can
actually construct worlds where uh NP is
easy so there are no 1A functions and
yet nevertheless you have two random
States uh so the sort of two versions of
this result one that uses a a Quantum
black box or a Quantum Oracle where we
can show that you know bqp and qma which
are kind of the quantum generalizations
of p and MP coincide and yet
nevertheless you still get pseudonym
States relative to this Oracle uh and
similarly in uh with in the more uh
standard classical Black Box setting we
can construct a black box world where uh
p is equal to NP and yet nevertheless
you still have pseudo-andm States and
hence by the reductions uh by the
security reductions that have been shown
in other words you get a wide range of
quantum cryptography even though uh
since P equals NP you don't get
classical cryptography
uh and in fact we actually even show
something uh Stronger in the second
result we basically introduce a concrete
hardness property of a cryptographic
hash function that both simultaneously
yeah it like plausibly holds for
existing cryptographic cache functions
but it also is independent of the P
versus NP problem
so this is kind of surprising this is
saying we can have Quantum cryptography
without classical cryptography or you
know putting another way uh if we go
back all the way to the first slide
where you know classically uh
you know uh super polynomial secure
cryptography is Unthinkable anywhere
above this line uh quantumly it's
actually consistent with our knowledge
that you could still have uh secure
Quantum cryptography based on
pseudo-andm States all the way up here
which is pretty remarkable
concrete
concrete uh
uh uh pseudo random assumption
or you have some concrete uh yeah
there's like a concrete assumption you
can make above a cryptographic hash
function like shot three where we show
that this property implies the existence
of secure pseudo to random States but
this property is also independent of the
P versus NP problem
um
and I guess I'll wrap up by just talking
about you know life what I think are
some of the most important research
directions for future work
um I think the first one is kind of can
we get other plausible instantiations of
pseudo-andom states that you know very
clearly don't rely on one-way functions
in any way because you know in some
sense the
uh the one I mentioned earlier it still
kind of relies on like some sort of
cryptographic hash function and while
you are using a different property of
this this hash function then what we
normally use in classical cryptography
you know it would be interesting to if
we could see like whether you know there
are other constructions of pseudo random
states that really you know clearly are
not going through these types of
hardness assumptions
and uh finally I think what I think is
maybe the most important question is do
any of these Quantum cryptographic
Primitives imply uh a classical hardness
result like a standard complexity
theoretic hardness assumption like P is
different from P space
um for some of these cryptographic
Colonials we can show something like
this so for the version of pseudonym
states that I defined here you can
actually show that if pseudoanimate
States exist when you get uh P actually
p is different from P to the sharp p
but uh for other things like for example
for for uh commitments we don't know
actually whether you can tie the
existence of such a Quantum
cryptographic primitive back to a
classical complexity hardness assumption
and uh yeah whether we can close that
Gap or whether you know Quantum uh
complexity assumptions really are just
something separate I think is a really
interesting question
and I think I will stop there I'd be
happy to take any questions
[Applause]
any questions
in metacomplexity relating one-way
functions with conditional Commodore of
complexity is there anything like that
known for Quantum setting
good
um not that I'm aware of I will say that
like some of the meta complexity results
were kind of exactly the kinds of
questions that got me motivated about
these questions originally because I was
wondering like you know can we
can we tie like uh you know the hardness
of quantum cartography back to some meta
complexity assumption and uh that was
like how I Came Upon This first result
actually but but yeah actually I don't
really know
that's a good question
yeah I think in general kind of Quantum
meta complexities in my opinion a bit
understudied I think that there's a lot
of big questions there
it was a reading group on Quantum meta
complexity in Spring
any other questions
that's between us and lunch so yeah yeah
I want to hold things up but there was
this example uh I I guess something
Quantum money or something that you you
didn't explain at the very beginning of
your talk oh yeah so so the quantum
money example so you can basically
um you can mint banknotes using Quantum
information that are physically
impossible to counterfeit
um so so if you allow the banknote to be
you know stored as a Quantum state by
like polarizations of photons or
something which is quite you know
impractical from an engineering
standpoint
um
but you know theoretically it's
interesting I should know that the the
quantum key distribution protocol is
actually a lot more practical uh so this
picture uh these protocols have actually
even been demonstrated between like a
ground station and a satellite
it's just pretty remarkable
like probably take other questions
offline um thank you
[Applause]
foreign